yesterday
we
already heard a lot of instances when
uh
the problem of deciding whether one
orbit is lying in the closure of another
arises and i would like to discuss this
problem in complete generality
uh and my point
will be that of hilbert
who
trying to
answer
criticism by gordon and poncare and
others about
theological nature of his pro for first
fundamental theorem of invariant theory
published
in 1890
a big paper
trying to to do
the same but
using
what we see now
constructive approach
to avoid
just statements about existence
and
he
didn't bother
about
complicatedness of algorithmic he was
trying to find about complexity
and my point will be the same i
will try to describe an algorithm
answering this question
uh in a constructive way
but
i will not speak about complexity and
this is an interesting
problem
and
challenging problem
uh showing that uh
there's a room for improving these
algorithms to try to find
another ones
so the setting will be the following uh
i will fix the ground field k
which will be algebraically closed
and
i will not bother about characteristic
it
it may be arbitrary at one place i will
require that it is zero but i suspect
that
this is superfluous and uh actually all
the rest uh
nothing to do this jurisdictional
characteristic
assume that i have a
finite dimensional vector space v
over this field
let n will be this dimension
and assume that i have a
algebraic
a fine algebraic
group
which i assume connected
acting linearly
and algebraically on v
the problem which i would like to
address is the following assume that i
have two points
in the two vectors
how can we
find out
whether
orbit of a
lies
in the closure
of orbit of b
and find out in a constructive way this
will be the problem
uh
actually uh you may say that uh well
there are
examples of the same question when
such a group acts not linearly on the
vector space but on some
say a fine variety
yesterday we had seen a lot of examples
so quasi-fine variety or even more
generally in quite a projective variety
but
i will explain that in a sense
all these problems are reduced to this
one
and briefly the reason to say for find
varieties is that any fine variety and
dot with action
algebraic action of algebraic group can
be equivalently embedded
in a linear action on some vector space
the same is true for quasi defined
varieties
and uh of course
quasi projection for ics cannot be
embedded in such view but there is a
trick which nevertheless reduces
everything to
to this case i will explain this a
little bit later
uh
before i i will move to the algorithm
let me
consider several examples there were a
lot of examples yesterday but
nevertheless
maybe it's a worthwhile to to consider a
little bit more
for instance let this will be my first
example
uh
and this will be the following one
uh assume that
i'll
use notation a
is
finite dimensional
vector space
or
over the same field
and i'm interested in the structures of
algebras
this l being underlying vector space of
such algebra by algebra i mean
uh
not necessarily a society of algebras
namely there is a multiplication should
be multiplication in l which is just
distributive
no other restrictions
and
such structure of algebra
is
defined by an element
of
this tensor product
which will be my v
in here
where star means dual space
and the definition is just the following
if you have a
an element in here which is the sum of
uh l i
tensor l dash
j tensor
k
i three k
where this is and here this isn't there
and this isn't here
then uh
multiplication of two vectors
designed just by definition
by this formula
and this is structure of algebra
and all algebras are obtained in this
way
the group g
will be
the full linear group of this vector
space l
and it acts on
this
v in a natural way
and
and um
it's easy to see
uh let me denote uh what will be in my
notation say a l of v
this algebra
uh
this is let me call this a
algebra
and you find
my point a
uh and it's easy to see that two
algebras are isomorphic
if and only if
these two points a and b
lie in the same orbit
the orbits are they classify algebras up
to isomorphism
uh and
we can consider this this question in
this setting
and if
we have
this inclusion
then we say that
not we it's in this theory of algebras
people say that
algebraic a
is the generation
of algebraic b
and there is a big theory about
degenerations and people study when this
degeneration
uh given two algebras when why one is
the generation of the other and it's
considered to be a complicated question
to to de decide
in general if we have two algebras
can we decide whether why one generation
or the other
but this is in my language it's just
this the question of of constructive
deciding
of
equation star
ah
another example
also comes from algebra
and this is as follows
i assume that l is the same
and its dimension
c is d
and assume that i have a
finitely
generated
associative
k algebra
and i'm interested in structures of
of
a modulus
l
this is uh can be considered as follows
if i fix here a basis
uh then linear operators
on ale
are just matrices
uh to define the structure of of algebra
a algebra here is the same as to say how
the generators are only finite many
generators of a
uh by definition of final generation is
how they act on element we should know
this and we know everything and this
means that if
a is say
a is
generated
by say m
elements
then structure of
a model on l is defined by uh m triple
of of matrices of size d by d which has
just just operators
by means the generators x on l therefore
uh if i consider
space of matrices
this is square matrices of size d by d
and times
then the structure of algebra on l is
just a point in here
but it's not arbitrary point because the
generators in a are subject to some
relations and therefore the images
should be subject to the same relations
and therefore we should consider only
the the m tuples such which are cut off
by by relations
to which
generators of a as a sub uh a subject
and this cutoff here sums up variety
also variety whose points are just just
the images of generators under the
structure of
a modulus on l
in the game we can do the same and
if i use notation
say
point a in here
if i use notation mx
this is a model
on l corresponding
to point x
then
the natural action of
g
l d
on the space by conjugation
splits the whole the x in is a bunch of
orbits and orbits they correspond to
a model
a modular structure on l up to
isomorphism
isomorphism of modulus if and only if
the orbits
are equal
and the same uh in this series is a big
theory and uh
for some specific algebras there are
some uh
some answers
um
this is use the same terminology if
this
type
small a small
yeah
a b
a b okay
uh
and if we have a conclusion then we say
that m a
is degeneration
and people study this
and
in some
cases there is answer
when we have this inclusion for instance
with that it's vanguard
studied
the case when
a
is a so-called pass
algebra
of a commuter
which is extended
diagram of type
simply last diagram
type a d or e
and pass algebra is just
the vector space is k algebra whose
bases are just passes
in this graph and multiplication is
given just by concatenation of passes
if it is possible or zero if it is not
possible so this is finitely generated
algebra and
in this case very specific case there is
a nice answer when this happens
but in general this is again considered
to be
quite complicated question
so is it any easier when x a is free so
just
x is the whole that's right that's right
if
it's free it's it's but again
in some nice cases it's possible to give
the answer but my point would be to to
input no restrictions on
just to consider this problem in
complete generality
let me also mention the following
application
and also
continue considering examples
application is the following
application of considering this question
and the application based on the fact
that in algebraic geometry
orbits and their closures
uh they have nice property which
doesn't hold for topological groups such
phenomena like uh um thoros of indian is
impossible in algebraic geometry and i
mean namely i mean the property that
orbit is open in its closure
because of this reason
if we have
both inclusions
then this nothing
but the statement that orbits are equal
but if we know how to solve this problem
we will solve it twice
in this case in this case if in both
cases we obtain answer yes this would
mean the orbits are
are equal
this would mean for instance in this
situation or in this situation this that
we get a mean to decide whether to
algebras whether to modulus isomorphic
or not
and there are another examples of
solving the problems
of classification or equivalency using
this approach
coming from algebraic geometry let me
give you a couple of examples
namely consider
consider
hypersurfaces
in the projective space
it will be example three
dimensional
projection space and then consider
hypersurfaces
um
given by
equation
where this is
a homogeneous
form
in in coordinates on pm
uh irreducible
i also
would like to impose a constraint that i
consider only smooth hypersurfaces
and it follows from the classical
theorem by siberia and ryoti and
leftshits
that if d which is degree of x
is bigger equals and four
and
n is also bigger or equal than four
then
such
hypersurfaces
h1 and adh2
x1 and x2
are isomorphic as algebraic varieties
if and only if the corresponding forms
uh so this is
locus of f0
f1 and this is of f2
uh
and
s2
are in the same
uh
g n plus one orbit
working naturally on projective space
so we reduce the geometric equation of
uh algeb
isomorphism of algebraic varieties so
the equation of
of the type is which are considering we
have linear representation of g n plus
one on the spaces of forms of degree d
and then plus one variables and ask
whether they are in the same orbit or
not what happens in lower degrees well
there are some exceptions
uh
but uh this is just besides this case if
so if we can
answer the
question of
of
if we can solve the problem star and
apply in this situation then we can can
answer it in principle this question
whether just tell me the example in
degree three
oh i can i don't remember my heart
but there are some
some
plain elliptical
all right so this is isomorphic abstract
right
it's abstract
abstract right now no no no no maybe i i
i said this no no no it's abstract word
is that all right
uh so this is would be the solution and
the last example
uh is
by smooth projective
curves
most
objective curves
of genus
g bigger than two let's consider such is
such reducible curves
by a triple of canonical class every
such curve is embedded in projective
space
3k three times canonical class
embed such a curve in projective space
of dimension five
g minus six
where g is a genus
so carefully sits here
and
it is known that curves are isomorphic
genes in this abstract algebraic
varieties if and only if
images
of of these embeddings are in the same
orbit
uh
are transformed one to another by
instant projector transformation
are
transformed
by
projective transformation
one to another
uh but one can associate with uh define
actually such an image by its shell form
which is some
some
hyper surface like here
and again the
this condition
is the same as transformation of one
char form to another shallow form
and therefore we are in this situation
and can apply this
so in principle this gives you the way
to decide whether two
curves of this type
are
isomorphic as object where i just don't
know
okay this is my examples
now uh i i would like to discuss these
uh
and for
this i
this this will be some algorithm
uh
but
in every algorithm
i should know what is
known what is input
and that will be output
therefore let me first describe
say something about input
first of all
i will fix a basis in this vector space
v
uh and i will uh i will illustrate what
what i am
speaking about by means of considering
the
the classical example of binary forms
which was the subject of study of
classical researchers
and illustrate
all the things which i'm speaking using
these examples
so fix the basis here
uh the case when dimension is one is
trivial
so let me assume so it's easy
so
from now on and i will assume that n is
bigger or equal than two
if i fix the basis then
the action of g
is described
in matrix language namely
every element of g
is mapped to
to
linear operator on v linear operator
when we fix the pages is a matrix
so this is
so the
we have
action
given by
homomorphism of g
algebraic homomorphism of g into glv and
gleev
because of these pages will be
identified with space of matrices
j and k
and therefore
every
element is
mapped to a matrix
and the matrix has matrix entries
which depend on g
um this functions
g is mapped to
to
rho i j o g
is a regular function polynomial
function on algebra algebraical
i'll use notation for regular functions
this will be my standard notation not
not o of g but k of g
and
i will assume
so assume
that these functions are known to me
i'll consider example and you will see
what's going on
now um further i i need a notation
uh
let
rs
vote face a
raise to the power rs
will be
an open subset
in a fine space of dimension r plus s
such that
first
our
entries are non-zero
so what i'm doing i'm just throwing away
from
this
coordinate refine space
several
coordinate hypersurfaces
and the the open set which i obtained is
denoting this way
i'll denote by x i standard
our coordinate
functions
on
on this space
and given by by
condition that its value on this
yes
then
algebra of polynomial regular functions
on this fine
variety
is
generated by x1
up as s but first
are axis they are invertible
so
they are regular therefore
look at them so this is this algebra
ah and all possible monomials
of the type
x1 raised to a1
plus s
where i 1 ir
are any integers and the rest are
natural numbers
all possible monomials is the basis
of this infinite dimensional vector
space over my field k this is basis
uh i will now use the following remark
let me call it lemma
so i'll call you that i have a fine
algebraic group connected and no
restrictions on a on g are imposed and
the lamb is the following
for some
r and s
there is a
dominant
regular
map
of this
variety
into variety g
moreover
i don't need there is some freedom you
can
i need to fix some map let me call it
hyota
somewhere of this type but there are
plenty of them and among them there is
even an open embedding
and i will not use it but
just just as a remark
i will fix such such such such iron and
work with it
um
and
if i is fixed
these functions are given
so then i have
this will be a
function through i j and this is my yota
which gives me
the the the functions iota star
rho i j
it should be regular functions on this
defined variety
which are therefore
some linear combinations with
coefficients and k of these
monomials
can you say what
be just in the is of g here then
you are a little
bit ahead of me i'll give you example in
in 10 seconds
uh
so this is some some functions lying in
in this
this algebra
so i will assume that they are not not
only
these row i j are known but these
functions are
known etc
let me consider the example of binary
forms
and they are known to me
example
my g will be a cell 2.
and
my v will be space of binary forms in
two variables as example
let me call it vh so this is binary
forms
in variables uh i will denote them
by z
z1 and z2
of
degree
h
this is h plus one dimensional
vector space
and group x
so if g is matrix alpha beta
gamma delta
then the action
on the first variable
is alpha
z1 plus plus gamma z2
and on the second is d to z1 plus
delta z2
so this is how it acts on this vector
space
and
as an example of such iota
i will consider
uh the following
map
so it maps
this three-dimensional
epson one epsilon to epsilon3
it maps to the two matrix and matrix
which which i would like to consider
will be the following this will be one
uh
epsilon two
this will be diagonal matrix
so this will be
if you multiply
you will get
the following
1 minus 1
epsilon 2 epsilon 3
epsilon 1
so 1 minus 1 epsilon 3
1 minus 1
1 minus 1 epsilon 2.
and
when these epsilons vary
then
you may see that the the whole totality
of this matrix is is stands in the cell
2 so the map is indeed dominant as i
need so this dominant map
uh this looks like it will give the
general proof too right yeah yeah but
absolutely so this is
this is the simplest example of what is
called
blue cell big big big brass cell in sl2
so in any group
in any reductive group there is such a
such a phenomenon
uh
these functions uh rho
pq or ij are defined in the following
way
uh
let me let me just give you the answer
and and this is the rest so you know
this
monomials z1 z2
this is degree
h minus j and j this is this monomials
when g runs from 0 to 2 to n to n to h
they constitute a basis in this in the
space of v h
and uh such a monomial under
the
transformation
g
uh is obtained if you plug in instead of
z z1 and z2
uh
these
forms
raise it and expand so the result will
be
rho
i plus 1 i plus 1 because i i
count the entries of the matrix not from
the zero but from one
uh j plus one
g
z one h minus one z two
all right
so this is my functions
but if i i would like to
to have uh
yotostar of these functions then the
recipe will be the following you should
um
you should should do the following you
you could have to
uh
using using this this
matrix take x1 plus x1 minus 1 x2 x3
z1
plus
x1 minus 1 x3
and z2 raise this to
h minus j
x1 minus 1 two
z one plus x one minus one
z two and h is two to g
and this will be sum of monomials in z1
and z2 with some coefficients and these
coefficients are just precisely these
functions which i'm interested in for
instance if h is 2
and u is expanded then i star of rho2
will be 1 minus 2 x 1 minus 2 x 2 x 3.
so this is just very explicit
and i assume that these functions are
known to me
so this will be one half of the input of
the algorithm this this is
these functions the another
part is just one number
it has geometric meaning
and
i will denote it by d
and it's in this place where i will use
assume
that characteristic is zero but i
suspect that this this is this can be
can be it's redundant it can be can be
dropped actually but let's assume
because i will use some result uh by
kazarnowski in which in which
he
uses this assumption actually he uses
the assumption that filter c but i
suspect that this is not not really
important
so
anyway
the second
part
of the input
this is first part these these functions
and second part is just one number and
this number is d
which is degree
of
this thing
which is sits in g l and k
which sits in the space of matrices of
size n by n which is nothing but n
squared coordinate vector space
so
this row g is is this algebraic
subroutine here and it's known as is
closed in here therefore we have in this
vector space some algebraic variety this
one
and every algebraic variety in
particular this one has a has a degree
is the following thing so in a vector
space you have algebraic variety
and then you take a
hyperplane of the complementary
dimension
in this vector space
it intersects somehow this this variety
and almost for all such hyperplanes for
generic hyperplanes the number of points
of intersection is the same
this number is called degree
once again
you have your variety
intersected with the have
with a
a fine
subspace of a complementary dimension
uh and count the number of points of
intersection and it appears such theorem
that
that for almost all such
uh if i find
subspaces this number is the same this
is degree
and i i need to know this degree so is
there a
way to
compute this in general for groups this
is what i want to explain to you so it's
it's possible to to answer what is it
uh it appears so i need this number for
for
in my input and it appears that it's
possible to to calculate it
uh
oh i'm i'm
i am afraid that
i don't really have time to do this
i have to finish in in eight minutes
right ten minutes ten minutes
uh
then let me put it like exit since uh uh
this is just sort of preparation so i
explain uh you what is the input but
then the algorithm
let me postpone if i will not have time
then just to those who are interested
i'll explain that this d
can be calculated explicitly
in particular i plan to consider example
of binary forms this one
and using this result
one can obtain the following answer it
is just a matter of calculating some
integral elementary integral which
students is doing in calculus and answer
will be the following degree
of rho of g in this case
will be
twice h cubed or h cube
depending
whether
um
h is solder or even
it's calculatable
it can be calculated
next remark again i have no time
to explain this
not difficult but
should be explained in more details
since i have no time for this
let me just formulate it
remark
in a problem star
this one
i can always assume
that
a and b are no zero points
zero is not there
and
orbits
are conical
hey ay also
is it again
so it is
it can
nevertheless
both both are not equal to zero
replacing v by another vector space you
can reduce this to the case when when
both are non-zero and and and the orbits
are conical a is equal to zero is
interesting
all right but a is equal to zero and v
but but in another space it will be not
zero if you if you this is what i mean
so replacing v by by another
vector space and g by another group
you can reduce this to the to the case
which i specified here
both are nonzero and conical so let's
assume this
again i have no time to explain and now
finally the algorithm
uh
so i have degree i have these functions
uh and assume that this
this this holes and now now
what about the algorithm
the algorithm is the following
one
after you mark the following changing
bases
they may assume may and shell
that
b
which is beta 1 e 1
beta n e n has the property that all
coordinates are nonzero
uh and i also assume coordinates for for
um for a alpha one
a1
so
this coordinates alpha and beta are
known to me and i assume that all
bitters are non-zero
so
that's one
consider
and
polynomials
f1
and
of
degree
2g minus 2 g is known to me so
i can do this
in variables new variables
1 y1 yn
so this will be like that
some
some coefficients sorry
this is
one n
and
some natural numbers
such that their sum
is almost 2 d minus 2
and these coefficients
will be also variables they will be
algebraically independent over k
so
for me at the moment these y's are
variables but these
coefficients so these are genetic
polynomials they they are there
they also have the properties that this
all this c they are algebraically
independent
now these polynomials i need this
because from from this paragraph i will
cook another one
namely
i call it h
minus two
so consider
you know
just one polynomial made of these f's
namely the following one y one minus
first coordinate on my of my point a
alpha one times f1
plus etc
yn minus alpha n
consider this polynomial
minus
will be h
step two
plug in
this polynomial
in place of y
the following thing
beta which have coordinates of my b
here i use these functions which are
known to me
so plug in and center for this wise this
guy
and expand
the result will be
sum
of so these functions
they are functions in x i's
which which are the the functions on
this standard standard
so to speak a fine space with removed
coordinate hyperplanes so this will be
some of monomials in this six eyes
some coefficients which i'll denote by l
and remarkable thing that you
immediately see this
that this else they are linear forms
in this coefficient c
we never raised c using this
approach to some power
we just plugged in
this is a linear form
in this coefficient c
now i'm ready to to give the answer
theory
uh
the following properties are equivalent
what property
orbit of a lies in the closure of
the orbit of b this is what we are
interested in
and second property is the following
consider system of linear equations
which are just this else
linear
equations
and the requirement is
that this system is incompatible
there's no solutions
using chronic capillary theorem this
means that the ranks of
corresponding matrices are different
which is
possible
to verify
and this is equivalent
to this geometric property
one orbit is sitting in the core of the
lab
that's it
so uh i should stop here because of the
time reason
i'm sorry that uh
i
i had to skip this details about d this
is
it's very nice the answer is very nice
so could you at least get the idea of
how you compute the degree of row of z
just the idea
first of all it's a theory of
kazarinovsky as i told you it's not me
so could you state maybe the theorem
yes but for this i need some notation
but since uh we have discussion and
therefore some 10 15 minutes therefore i
can spend it for for for more
formulation or not
okay
okay maybe you can just explain how you
complete this degree
i maybe
but they they want to to
to to see the formulation of ethereum
maybe i'll do this and then you uh
okay
should i formulate this theorem or not
is there not like a simple statement if
you compute the hilbert polynomial of
the variety and look at the reverse
coefficient
by integrating over the politico
this is actually uh using the modern
language uh computing these degrees is
related to the theory of spherical
varieties intersection theory on this on
this spherical barrage that's
satisfactory this is this this is what
what is what is hidden there
this intersection theory on spherical
varieties that's it because there's
another question yeah so what what's
what's
what seems threatening here is that you
have this degree
that is 2d minus 2 you just you look at
engineering polynomials okay
okay
again just short remark just to give you
some some uh
i use in in the proof
uh efficient form
of hilbert nurse tell themselves
okay
and it comes from there
and this is result by by yellowneck who
obtained such such format when i applied
any questions or comments
so i don't understand this in
compatibility condition you just mean
that the rank is full of that in our
system
just no solution at all it's not it's
it's not homogeneous
no no i didn't say this it's just just
linear
system there is a solution yes
i mean it's different
so suppose there is a solution then
there is no container but because the
solution
is within the javascript
something like this and you assume
that the i mean the solution is the
coefficients of your polynomial
you assume that they were divided
independent
no no no no no no no no the solution is
not coefficients of my polynomials
coefficients of my polynomials are
variables of this system yeah right so
solving this means giving values to this
coefficient
giving values to this coefficient
precisely
yes
independent which was an assumption
in the construction of the polynomial
oh can i just make variables it's
amazing this is a way to make variables
for system of linear equations this is
where i'm taking from these variables
from these coefficients and that's it
well if you have system of linear
equations its variables are independent
right but it may have solutions which
which is not not independent that's just
precisely this
look as a question i wonder if can you
just advertise this
theorem what orbits have you been able
to separate or not
uh using the method if you have a list
of orbits that you're successful well
this is just this concerns uh
well
if you remember i started my lecture
with with
the remark that
i didn't bother
about complexity i didn't so if you
apply this for instance to binary forms
uh
and try to to figure out what what it
gives us here you obtain
enormous amount of variables
of this system an enormous amount of of
equations if i remember correctly if you
take binary forms of degree four
then this method give you
a
system
in which the number of variables is
uh
something like 56 millions
it's it's huge
it's very very big
so so applying this
applying this in
but but this is like
just precisely the same situation as
with hilbert's proof of the first
fundamental theorem he he proved that
this is possible to do but if you try to
apply this in concrete situations to
binary forms of small degree you you are
killed more or less
quickly
it's
it's not
directly applicable
for practical purposes
so then you criticize your own thing you
must have something that you like i
didn't criticize i just
there should be some some person like i
don't know who
who expert in in in complexity theory
but this is as i told the the the area
where you can
try to move further to to improve
this side of the problem but i just
didn't attempt this so far
at least to my knowledge uh so far it
was just some necessary conditions some
when when one orbit is
is not in the core of the other but
now this is just just if and only
okay more questions
always exponentially the number of
variables in this effectiveness
yes
i don't see why i don't see this in your
results or is it somewhere or
like how can you how can you see how
what is the way to see the could be the
way to see this
the number of coefficients in the extra
equations that he gave were higher
degrees as i told you the the
the number of coefficients uh is is huge
it's a number of i see these
let me take a look at
the coefficients of these genetic
polynomials are just many many many
that's right
it's not that big degree not that big of
a
number
number that's right
but still it could be worse i mean but
the coefficients are many and the degree
is very high but it doesn't seem to be
the case
it's not asymptotic but just to give the
flavor of of
of magnitude of this
so in the case of binary forms the
number of variables
uh can be with some coefficients it's
something like h to the h twice h
something like this
is
binary forms of degree h
and the number of variables is
something like this
such huge number
okay h to the twice h and this is
e to the edge
okay so one last question
yeah might be respect
so for this
orbit closure problems or closure of
anything being contained in another i
mean there is obvious well not obvious
but
algorithms from quantified elimination
that allows you to decide that right and
then those will be singly exponential in
the dimension
because these are constructable sets and
you want to say that the closure of one
is containing the others
so
what i want to say is that there is
always some simply exponential algorithm
this is an interesting question which i
would like to figure out what one could
expect here is it because uh
uh
something something huge should be here
or this is because of
uh
the method bad yes i don't know
for instance in in the case of
invariant theory
when hilbert obtained his
his
bounds upper bounds of the degrees of
polynomials well it gave again huge
number of calculations and it was
not because of this reason was not
applicable
from a practical point of view but only
the reason development showed that this
is not because method is bad but because
algebras are complicated
and this strict mathematical statement
one can explain what what this means
because there's a lot of synthetics
there and it's just complicated algebras
and i don't know what is hidden here it
is a similar story
is it because the problem is is really
or or our methods are better i don't
know
okay
foreign